we saw on Instagram on the comedy
Mothership Instagram you hanging out
with a bunch of comedians at Ms after
the show how was that experience and was
there any really cool moments that you
want to share or maybe the coolest
person that you got to meet yeah I mean
that was just absolutely insane I got to
you know have a really special moment
with Tony I had a really special moment
with Shane backstage right before I got
on he was like giving me a pep talk and
that was crazy it was like he was my
guardian angel it was weird but yeah it
was super cool I don't have much words
for it cuz it was just I I never
expected anything like that to happen at
all